what's happening of course to Nancy
Pelosi is that she knows she's about two
weeks from losing her house majority
status and the evidence of that is she
doesn't believe in polls anymore she
always likes Bulls when they're going to
her Advantage she doesn't like them
anymore and she's ignoring she doesn't
accept that most people actually don't
necessarily care about Ukraine that much
they certainly don't care about January
6th that much but they do seem to care
about crime and inflation
let's talk about Rising inflation
concerns along with crime giving
momentum new momentum to Republicans
after the Democrats were closing the Gap
in the historic Gap yes so
after the Supreme Court ruling there was
huge outrage that has seemed to subside
at least among overriding concerns first
of all let me say that I think that much
of what you've said I don't agree with
that is to say the New York Times poll I
think is an outlier poll you decide one
poll but all the others it's also the
real clear politics average is showing
similar issues no but they but that was
one that brought down the average and it
was an outlier it wasn't even that big a
sample so I I dismissed that oh Nancy
Nancy Nancy look I don't love polls
either and there are outlier polls and
all that but the simple truth is
everyone knows everyone knows ask
anybody ask yourself
stop this video right now pause it and
ask yourself while it's live but ask
yourself this question what am I not
happy with in America right now and the
two things on everyone's mind is
inflation I.E the economy and crime
those are the two big things and who's
dropping the ball on that whose cities
have the most crime whose cities have
the crazed unemployment and have all the
homelessness and the crime that comes
with it and all of that stuff and who is
in charge that is crushing the economy
leading to all of these problems it is
the Democrats so Nancy may not like
these polls but Nancy uh you in danger
girl as Whoopi Goldberg said in a ghost
remember that Molly you in danger uh
here's Nancy Pelosi going all in on
Biden because she's in on it her and gay
Pete and then Kamala all they've got is
Biden got us here so we got to go down
with the [ __ ] but in some cases there's
no substitute for experience and I think
that what we had been through with the
legislation under the leadership of
President Biden who has done a
spectacular regular job he's had a
better two years than most presidents
that you can name certainly in the
recent Generations
like what planet is she on what planet
are you on Nancy Pelosi I'll have what
she's having because the woman is on
something special
it's absolutely insane he's spectacular
he's done a better job than most
presidents in recent memory what are you
talking about every metric look at the
stock market today look at your 401k
you wander around New York City see
what's going on it's a debacle this is
presidency is a debacle and a sham and
as Phoenix just said to me could you
just imagine if Biden ran again could
you just I mean imagine where Biden will
be at mentally and physically in two
years you know what I say do it I'm all
for it you know you guys want to keep
pretending this is real keep going go go
with the lie you don't have much else